Còn lửa bốc lên từ hiện trường vụ giời mấy bài chính đấu A8-6B của Mỹ,
Phi công kịp phong ghế thoát hiện an toàn.
Sự cố sẻ ra ngày 3 mốt tháng bài, theo AP, thuê quân lục chính Mỹ cho biết,
tìm kích tạng hình A8-6B, thuộc phi đoàn thuê quân lục chính số mềm một,
lao xuống trước đường bằng tại cạnh cứ không quân miệm ra ở San Diego, bằng California.
Phi công kịp phong ghế bung dụ thoát hiện và được đưa đi cấp cứu.
Lực lợ cứu hả đã phương bỏ giập lửa lình sắc mấy bài và sử li đám trái xuống quân hiện trường.
Thuy quân lục chính xác định vụ tay nạn thuộc sự cố loại á, mức nghiêm trọng nhất.
AP Bà M'i Lâm B'i là phía bản được phát triển cho thuy quân lục chính Mỹ,
nổi bật nơi khả năng SDOVL, cho phép hoạt động chính các tổ độ bộ có sản đáp nhỏ hưởng tổ sân bài thông thường.
Mối trường AP Bà M'i Lâm B'i có giả xuất sử hơn 1,5 lịch chính trị OSD.
Ngoài thuy quân lục chính Mỹ, một số quốc gia đình mình của Washington cũng đặt mua và đăng biên trị rằng AP Bà M'i Lâm B.